Grüß euch und herzlich willkommen hier
am Truppenübungsplatz in Allentsteig.
Mein Name ist Wachtmeister Kaufmann Manuel vom
Institut "Panzer-Panzergrenadier" in Zwölfaxing.
Ich werde euch heute etwas über das
Waffensystem Leopard 2A4 erzählen.
Ich würde sagen wir fangen gleich
mit dem Rundgang an. Kommt mit!
Grundsätzlich unterscheidet
man bei dem Leopard zwischen
den sich oben befindenden Turm
und unten haben wir die Wanne.
Hier haben wir die schweren Kettenblenden,
darunter haben wir eine Gleisgliederkette. Die
Gleisgliederkette wiegt ungefähr 2,5 Tonnen.
Das ist vergleichbar mit einem Golf 3.
Hier haben wir unseren Tank,
dieser hat ein Fassungsvermögen von
1160 Liter. Es ist ein relativ sparsames
Fahrzeug. Wir verbrauchen ungefähr 3,4 Liter
auf einem Kilometer. Schauen wir weiter.
Wir haben hier die leichten
Kettenblenden. Die hinterste Kettenblende
aufgeklappt ,damit wir uns den Dreck
nicht selbst in das Laufwerk ziehen.
Es könnte nämlich sein das
sich die Kette dadurch löst
und dann heißt es wieder unnötig Arbeiten.
Wir haben hier denn Antriebszahnkranz .
Die Aufgabe des Antriebszahnkranzes
ist, die Kraft des Motors
auf die Kette zu übersetzen.
Gehen wir weiter. Jetzt kommen
wir zum Heck des Panzers.
Das Heck hat hier die Auspuffgretings
mit den Abschleppseilen. Hin und wieder
kommt es vor das sich ein Panzer fest fährt
und für das haben die Abschleppseile, damit
wir die Panzer wieder heraus ziehen können.
Gehe wir weiter zu der linken Seite des Panzers.
Diese ist bis auf eine Kleinigkeit
identisch zur rechten Seite.
Wir haben hier die ABC
Schutz-und Belütfungsanlage.
ABC steht für atomar, biologisch
und chemische Kampfstoffe.
Das heißt, sollte ein Angriff mit diesen
Kampfstoffen statt finden, haben wir
die Anlage die dafür sorgt das wir
keine ABC-Schutzmaske tragen müssen.
Wir schallten diese Anlage ein und
müssen dadurch keine Schutzmaske
oder andere Schutzausrüstung tragen.
Jetzt würde ich sagen, wenn wir
schon bei der Einstiegshilfe stehen,
sitzen wir auf und schauen
uns das ganze von oben an.
Jetzt befinden wir uns am Kampfpanzer.
Ich werde euch jetzt erklären wie viele
Besatzungsmitglieder der Panzer hat und wo
sie sich befinden. Rechts unter mir
, in der Wanne sitzt ist der Fahrer.
Dahinter haben wir den Richtschützen
der durch das EMES durch schaut.
Das ist eine 12 fache Vergrößerung mit einem
Wärmebild. Der Richtschütze
hat die Aufgabe zu schießen
beziehungsweiße den Turm zu schwenken. Hinter
dem Richtschützen sitzt der Kommandant das
bin in diesem Fall ich. Der Kommandant
hat die Aufgabe den Panzer zu führen und
sich im Gelände zu orientieren.
Links vom Kommandanten sitzt
der Ladeschütze, der Ladeschütze lädt
Bordwaffen und in einer Betriebsunterbrechung
kocht er einen guten Kaffee.
Die Hauptbewaffnung des Leopard 2A4
ist die 120mm Panzer-Glattrohrkanone.
Wir haben zwei Munitionsarten. Einmal die KE
und die MZ. KE bedeutet Kinetische Energie.
Diese Munition wird dazu verwendet auf
andere Kampfpanzer zu schießen. Die MZ
schießt auf weichere Ziele oder
auf leicht gepanzerte Ziele.
Außerdem hat jedes
Besatzungsmitglied eine P80 mit.
Links von der 120mm Glattrohrkanone
befindet sich ein koaxial eingesetztes
7,62mm Turmmaschinengwehr.
Dies ist ein belgisches
Maschinengewehr. Koaxial heißt ,dass
die Kanone und das Maschinengewehr
immer auf der selben höhen sind und
dadurch schießen wir genau dort hin
wo der Richtschütze hin schaut. Das
war es natürlich noch nicht.
Wir gehen weiter nach hinten.
Das ist das Maschinengewehr vom
Ladeschützen. Das 7,62 mm Maschinengewehr
wird zur Flankesicherung und kann
auch infantristisch eingesetzt werden.
Außerdem haben wir auf beiden Seiten am Heck
des Turmes eine Mehrfachwurfanlage. Diese Anlage
kann vor uns eine Nebelwand bilden damit
wir uns dahinter zurückziehen können.
Zu guter letzt schauen wir in den Panzer hinein.
Jetzt befinden wir uns auf dem Ladeschützeplatz.
Die Hauptaufgabe des Ladeschützen
ist das laden der Bordwaffen.
Wir haben hinter mir den Munitionsbunker
Turm. Der Munitionsbunker fasst 15 Schuss.
Von hier nimmt der Ladeschütze die
Munition heraus, und lädt sie hier in die
Kanone.
Das sind die Aufgaben des Ladeschützen.
Jetzt schauen wir uns den Richtschützen an.
Jetzt sind wir auf dem Richtschützenplatz.
Die Hauptaufgabe des Richtschützen ist das
schwenken des Turmes und das führen des
Feuerkampfes. Der Richtschütze kann bis zu einer
Geschwindigkeit von 50 km/h während der
Fahrt schießen und trifft genau ins Ziel.
Wann der Richtschütze
schießen darf ,sagt ihm der Kommandant
und den Platz schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Jetzt sind wir auf dem Platz des Kommandanten.
Der Kommandant führt die Besatzung
und den Kampfpanzer. Außerdem hat er
eine Optik mit der er unabhängig
vom Richtschützen beobachten kann.
Er hat auch die Möglichkeit die Kanone zu
übernehmen und den Feuerkampf selbst zu führen.
Jetzt schauen wir noch zum Fahrer hinunter.
Passt, jetzt sind wir im Fahrerraum. Der Panzer
lässt sich fahren wie ein automatik Auto.
Der Panzer hat nach vorne eine Panzerung von 90cm.
Wir haben links die Bremse und rechts das Gas.
Jetzt müssen wir Gas geben weil unsere anderen 3
Panzer warten auf der Schießbahn schon auf uns.